You are listening to radio lab
lab.
Where do you live?
W and Y. C c? Yeah.
N. P. R. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
This is radio lab, the podcast.
Robert, Robert is not here. He is away.
So it's just me unfortunately. But I will do my best. So in this podcast, uh,
I want to dig a little deeper into something that we ran into in our last a new
full episode, which was on words
and green
door. So yeah,
we did an hour on the power of words and uh, we ended up talking with this guy.
Hello? Hello. Is this Dr Ferny? Huh? Hi, can you hear me?
The name Charles Ferny Hill.
I'm a writer and developmental psychologist from Durham University and we were
having this conversation with him about what happens to young kids when they
learn words to step up things that you know,
like what happens to the way they see the world.
And in the middle of the chat he said something kind of radical,
which was the four. They have words I don't think very young children.
Do you think
like think period did?
Was there a period at the end of that sentence you don't think that they think
period? I don't think they think in the way that I want to call thinking.
All right, which is a bit of a cheat,
but let me say what he meant is that thinking as he defines it is basically just
words sounding silently in your head and before you have those words in your
head, you can't think this is a controversial idea,
which we debated back and forth,
but for the next few minutes we're not going to debate it.
We're going to jump into it farther because whether or not you think it's true,
if you follow the idea all the way through as we're about to do,
it does lead you to some interesting places.
So first of all, this whole idea is this. Charles goes back to this Russian guy,
Russian psychologist named
Vigotsky Lev Vygotsky, and is he a contemporary dude? No,
he died in the 30s he was, he was active and anyhow, he came up with this idea.
It's really interesting notion of how kids learn to think and it all begins.
He said on the outside,
think about a small child who's sitting down solving a puzzle.
How come does that look like? It goes somewhere. You're
here,
you're sitting down and you're working together on a puzzlement and all you've
got to do is get these shapes into this board in the right kind of order.
If you watch any kid and it would that parent anywhere in the world doing this
kind of thing, you'll see them thinking together.
Having the child for example, picks up a picture of a boat and says, you know,
read it. Where am I going to put this piece? And then the mom says, well,
have a look at the fella. And
then the kids looks at the shape and says, oh, he's got that points a bit there.
And the mum says, right,
well can you see anywhere on the board that has a pointy bit right there and so
on. According to Vygotsky, this is the beginning of thinking,
this kind of dialogue and at this point is completely external.
It's all happening in that space between the child and her mother. It, yeah.
We don't know where it goes yet, but if you put it together and any over time,
does it become internalized and how that happens.
The gassy thought is that as the child gets older,
she'll start to take on the dialogue herself. She'll start to talk to herself.
This is the stage we called private speech. We've all seen kids do this, right,
where they narrate every single thing they're doing. Put the ball in the box,
take the ball out of the box.
Now what then happens is a few years further down the line,
these kids who are narrating everything they're doing then go to school and the
teachers tell them, shh, don't talk out loud.
So they kind of get the message that they need to start doing this internally.
So they start to whisper to themselves out loud,
and then eventually they whisper to themselves silently because the words are
now in their head. And that according to Vigotsky's theory,
that his thinking only then he says is the child having a thought?
Okay.
Now forgetting the particulars for a second.
The main point here is that those thoughts that are humming along silently in
your mind,
those thoughts began as a duo with your mom
or a trio with your mom and your dad or a quartet with your mom and your dad and
your sister. In other words, those thoughts began as a crowd.
The logic of it is that all our thinking is full of other people's voices.
[inaudible]
now, most of us know that the voices in our head are just us,
but what got us interested in this whole Vygotsky thing is it maybe this idea
has something to say to people who actually do hear other voices in their head.
Yeah. Hi. Hi. Nice to meet you. Thanks for coming up here.
As we were thinking about this, just so happened that our producer,
pat Walters had taken a trip to Denver, had a little time on his hands,
did a little research and ended up tracking down this late and I'm Molly Martin
and I am a psychotherapist and I run the hearing voices network of Denver.
They met up at this hotel.
Molly works with people who hear voices in their heads and she runs a support
group for people to share their experiences. The day pat was there,
she introduced him to a fellow named Mark [inaudible].
Hi, I'm Marcus Masias. Uh, I'm a voice here myself.
I hear voices so I can kind of share my experiences.
Can you kind of tell me this story of
well yeah. Um, you know, I first started hearing them 20 years ago,
so I've been hearing him for 20 years and so I'm 40 now,
so here's what, when I was 20,
when I first started hearing them, when it started for him,
he says the voices would kind of materialize out of background noise,
like the hum of a refrigerator or the wear of a fan.
When I first started hearing, um, they were kind of guiding a little bit,
you know, like guiding voices. Like she says,
initially the voices would help them out.
Like if he was in an argument and about to say something mean,
the voices would warn him, be careful, watch out. They say things like that,
you know, kind of like they were helpful. But then, uh,
there was like other negative ones. He's had periods in his life.
He says we were the voices of even turned demonic. Yeah. So that was intense.
Things are a lot better now though. She, I'm learning how to manage him,
you know, cause I'm taking care of myself. So, okay, so why do we bring this up?
Well, clearly for a lot of people,
like Marcus hearing voices involves some psychiatric issues,
which sometimes for people it can be serious, really serious.
But here's the weird thing.
The experience of hearing somebody else's voice in your own head is actually way
more common than you would think.
Surveys have been done about this and the number seems to be between five and
10% of normal healthy people have that experience or have had it at one time.
Which brings us back to this philosophy situation.
What might be happening in those cases, Lisa, if yes,
Charles is a kind of misattribution of your own inner voice.
Those voices in your head,
which are you get mistaken to be from someone else.
A Nice, simple,
elegant demonstration of this is that you take some people who are hearing
voices, people with, um,
in this case a diagnosis of schizophrenia who hear voices and you sit them down
at a microphone, some headphones on, and you show them some words on a screen,
just flush up some words on a screen. And their task is to repeat the words,
to read the words out loud.
Now if you can imagine these subjects are seeing these words on the screen,
they're repeating them into the mic and they've got headphones on.
So they're actually hearing their own voices as they're doing this trick is the
researchers have rigged it so that the voice in their headphones,
their voice actually gets lower just a little bit right before they hear it.
What that means is that if I were to say, hello, my name is Jad,
what I'd hear in my headphones is, hello, my name is Chad. And as you know,
she loaded the pitch of the voice by a few semitones.
It becomes much harder to recognize it because when I'm speaking in this lowered
voice, you can still kind of recognize it's me, but it's a little bit hard.
Now what the experimenters found is that most people,
most non voice hearing quote unquote healthy people when they were presented
with the sound of their own voice lowered like this and then asked, is this you?
Is it a stranger or you're not sure? They did make mistakes.
Some mistakes.
The voice here is made considerably more mistakes.
Really. Yeah. Not only that, when they heard their voices lowered,
they would very, very often say that voice is coming from a stranger.
That's not me. That's not myself. That didn't come from me.
Now of course that is potentially find new experience.
That is potentially a very distressing experience, but not always
[inaudible].
Cause let's just imagine that God ski was right,
that the internal voice of our thoughts is actually a blend of all of those
external voices from our childhood. So in other words that our mom,
our dad or sisters, brothers, whatever,
they're all in there in some way and that can actually be a comfort
back at that hotel in Denver. Molly Martin, yes.
Told pat about a woman who had seen her father murdered.
He was shot in front of her. Um, and she was,
it was a robbery and it was, I believe at a convenience store.
And for years afterwards, she says this woman would hear her dad's voice.
She would tell us that every morning when she would wake up,
he would tell her to make her bed and he would remind her throughout the day to
do more positive things. And if she was doing something, for example,
if she wanted, she was a drug addict and she wanted to use drugs again,
her father would say to her things like, you know, don't do it. You know,
it's bad for you. It's a horrible, you know, more looking after her.
I think she might've been 11 when he was killed, but
it was a good relationship during that time. Yeah.
And then it just kind of like stuck like frozen. Yeah, I think so. I think so.
[inaudible]
if you want to read some more about hearing voices,
you can do that on our website.
radiolab.org thanks to Charles Ferny Ho who wrote a great book called a thousand
days of wonder. Also thanks to Molly Martin, Marcus Macias,
Stella Story and Carrie Donahue and Joanna and Alex Lao.
They made the a homemade sonic id that you heard at the very beginning.
Okay, so before we go,
just want to let you know we have a new website@radiolab.org it's a new design,
it's all organized and if you go to the site, in fact, I'm gonna do right now.
All right, here we go.
radio.org if you go there and you scroll down to the middle,
you'll see a whole bunch of
frightening looking people wearing tee shirts. That is the radio lab staff,
myself and Robert included,
and you will all see us wearing a tee shirt depicting a goat standing
on a cow's back. This is a very meaningful image to us,
perhaps to some of you,
and if you just click a little bit more and you just follow the link to chop
shop, store.com you will see that we, oh, what a cute baby.
We have toddler sizes. I have a toddler.
I'm going to buy one for my toddler and by 70 in fact, here I go,
seven zero very. I'm going to make this purchase up so I should sign off.
I'm Jen, I boom. Rod, thanks for listening. Catch you in two weeks.